who wants to see this happen to america
who wants to because you know a lot of
times when you think about this stuff
you you think about proxy wars you think
about how some of these countries are
sitting there saying listen the way i'm
going to get to america is by pinning
xyz against them so they're playing
those games but who would like to see
america's way of living capitalism all
of that fall who would love to see that
happen
you're a good interviewer really these
are great questions uh my friend faizal
almutar who heads ideas beyond on
borders he's an iraqi refugee who's come
to this country he's an amazing human
being um he was telling me was spending
time with him was like dog years it's
like seven to one um he was telling me
that the the that many places in the
middle east primarily funded by china
and russia are have
stations dedicated to blm
dedicated to
the divisive madness that's currently
overtaking so basically the enemies of
the united states want to see this
succeed they want to see these
rebellions succeed meanwhile there are
people who
there are countries who are literally
putting their own citizens in
concentration camps and you don't hear a
peep about it from these folks when you
know you'll hear about a gender
imbalance at a conference but when isis
takes literal slaves and we know that we
have the videos from the slave bazaars
when they take yazidi women uh there's
not a peep there's not a protest there's
there's nothing you don't you don't hear
anything about it so
to answer your question directly there
are countries like russia and china and
iran to a certain extent who are
directly funding the blm and and the the
accoutrements are the kind of the um
conceptual drivers for this and then you
have the people on the far left the woke
far left in particular um who really
want to see the end to what they
consider to be an oppressive patriarchal
regime
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
what happens here by the way going back
to your book how to have impossible
conversation so when you're dealing in
an environment in a climate where 99 is
giving to one party and one percent is
given to the opposing party how do you
have those difficult those impossible
conversations with people from uh
the opposite aisle i mean how do you
have those conversations yeah that's
another really good question it's
actually really easy to have those
questions that once somebody when i
taught in prisons i did my dissertation
and i taught prison inmates how to think
through moral questions
and i
pulled from the history of western
philosophy you know
questions like what does it mean to be
what is justice and
she's so many questions
you know can you be unjust towards
yourself and what does it mean to be a
good man
when people will talk to you
already
even even if you think the the the gulf
or the divide is so great the moment
someone's talking to you
that's that's great um those
conversations are more far more possible
than you think
far more possible the problem is when
they won't talk to you and that's the
situation which we have now
these
the folks who participate in this
ideology they don't
um buy into the norms of civil society
they don't buy into reason discourse
evidence
and this is really important for your
audience to understand
so if if if let's say that you and i
want to figure out a problem let's say
we want to figure out you know we've
heard from armenians for example and and
armenians are claiming
that uh they're pulled over by the
police
at radically disproportionate rates than
non-armenians
you and i would sit down and say all
right man
we we got to figure this out how we're
going to do this and we'd say okay well
we're going to look at the
the body cams of people we're going to
every time someone calls in we're going
to see if they have an ian or the y and
which anybody doesn't know that's your
meaning last name
and we're gonna and then we're gonna
we're gonna kind of study this somehow
we're gonna figure out you know we're
gonna do a survey data whatever however
we're gonna do it okay that's how sane
rational people go about figuring stuff
out
these folks don't buy
the traditional tools that we would use
to solve problems reason
evidence
epistemic adequacy which basically means
you know knowing what you're talking
about
uh
what they would do is so they believe
this is this uh aubrey lloyd's the
master's tools cannot disable the
master's house the master's house is the
current system we have and it's
patriarchy racism oppression
so what built this this is their
thinking like what built the system well
evidence reason
you know
science to a certain extent
all these things so you can't disable
the patriarchy you can't disassemble it
through evidence and reason you have to
use something else like you have to
you know rip down statues you have to
get to tear stuff down you have to
whatever whatever
the the particular
brand of lunacy is you have to defund
the police
um you you have to
you have to make it so that the system
in place is just is disabled so if you
like this sort of shortcut from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]